bonsoir il faut tout d'abord remercié
d'être avec nous alors un président qui
traite un autre de tueur c'est assez
inédit à ma connaissance c'est même très
audacieux joe biden il va très fort
comment analyser ses propos je crois
d'abord c'est assez grossier ce langage
de mafieux qui est un peu surprenant
pour le président quand même d'un des
plus grands pays du monde et je crois
que là il me semble qu'il ya eu un
dérapage de du président biden aux frais
de remarques la première il faut pas
oublier que c'est un peu surprenant que
le président biden qui a été lu quand
même il ya comme une hypothèque terrible
ce son élection en france est très bien
accueilli du froid des normes et cie qui
se met à critiquer l'élection soit
disant frauduleuse de 2010 est enfin
tout ça est un peu surréaliste mais je
crois que derrière tout ça et camille
l'inquiétude que les européens doivent
avoir c'est parce qu'il faut pas oublier
que depuis 1945 faire depuis
pratiquement 75 ans les etats-unis ont
toujours été en guerre
sauf la période de trump c'est à dire
les quatre ans de prince n'y a pas eu de
guerre et là on a l'impression si vous
voulez avec ses déclarations très
agressives du président biden avec aussi
également ce plan de l'otan vous savez
autant 2030 qui veut en serre et les
européens dans une sorte de menace
contre la russie et la chine que vous
avez l'état profond américain qui est en
train de réagir et de déstabiliser
l'équilibré du monde
moi je suis très inquiet parce que c'est
vrai que nous avons actuellement une
compétition profonde entre la grande
puissance globale américaine qui a
apporté la guerre et de la paix
et puis surtout la puissance globe qui
est en train de monter la puissance
globale chinoise et on sent très bien
que derrière tout ça il ya cette
fracture qui est en train de s'imposer
et on voit très bien que les américains
sont furieux alors que c'est eux qui ont
poussé dans l'est
les rues la russie dans la main de la
chine sont un peu furieux de voir que
que les accords russo chinois sont
nombreux et je crois qu'en ce qui
concerne les européens nous avons
vraiment à la 7e je pense pas l'union
européenne soit capable de ça mais je
pense qu à des grands pays comme la
france devrait pouvoir réagir devant
cette pression des américains je ne sais
pas ce que pense le président macron
mais sérieusement à voir les anglais qui
ont déjà fait leurs plans hier deux pour
intégrer l'otan 2030 à voir les autres
pays de l'union européenne notamment les
allemands qui sont en train dans la
logique de ce qu'on voulait faire assure
du défense européenne un peu d'étouffer
si vous voulez la créativité française
aux entreprises
je suis très inquiet pour l'avenir parce
que j'ai vraiment l'impression que les
américains s'entraînent dans céret
l'europe dans un combat futur et c'est
pas de soi il n'est pas de bon augure
il faudra d'abord gaujean revient quand
même à ces mots durs parce qu'il frappe
et effectivement c'est quasiment une
attaque personnelle d'un homme un autre
homme il se trouve que les deux sont son
président que c'est a des répercussions
au niveau des relations diplomatiques
mais en moins joe biden précise qu'il
souhaite continuer à travailler avec
moscou sur les dossiers comme comme le
nucléaire mais on a du mal à imaginer la
suite delà de la relation d'autant que
moscou a rappelé l'ambassadeur
ce soir ce qui est plutôt rare comment
peuvent se passer les choses par la
suite pendant ce que je peux espérer
c'est que c'est ce que je peux espérer
c'est que c'est vrai que l'accord du
nucléaire est très important entre
l'alma entre l'amérique et et la russie
c'est quelque chose de fondamental alors
je peux espérer que c'est mon peu
dérapages ou un excessive et de langage
du président biden
mais en même temps ils menacent de
sanctions alors déjà des sanctions qui
pèsent sur la russie qui sont des
sanctions un peu stupide enfin qui
n'apporte rien saut dans un contexte de
pandémie on a besoin que le monde de
saut vrai puis vous avez des européens
et les américains qui continuent à
mettre dépendez des sanctions sont là
aussi tout ça est ridicule
alors qu'on a besoin d'eux lorsque la
pandémie va commencer à s'arrêter à ce
que le montre s'ouvre à ce que les
échanges reprennent en face des pôles
économie mondiale et là je suis je
n'arrive pas bien comprendre que le fait
les américains en même temps s'il vient
d'un autre côté ils peuvent taper pour
dire voilà on peut peut-être mieux
négocier je ne sais pas sérieusement je
ne peux pas vous répondre là dessus
ce saut je trouve que c'est ces mots là
sont des mots vulgaires et sont des mots
qui ne sont pas dignes d'un président de
la république fin d'un président d'un
grand état comme les les états unis
alors nous pouvons espérer que si vous
voulez que damman le bidet ne va pas
regretter ces mots là parce que c'est la
logique du cowboy salut comment ils
adorent les coups de feu les aime
l'école tahiti rouge
c'est la logique des colts mais j'espère
s'ils voulaient que derrière tout ça la
diplomatie américaine un diplomatie
russe arriveront à avoir un travail
important de de concertation parce que
nous les européens avons nous aime ça
nous sommes entraînés dans une tension
entre la russie et l'amérique est
stupide alors que le/la la russie est un
plus grand pays européen et nous les
européens nous sommes à cause des
américains cette tension que mater
américain pas ses relations avec la
russie
nous sommes entraînés dans ce combat qui
n'est pas notre combat etc je crois que
ça c'est le problème de l'avenir alors
j'espère que les américains sauront la
diplomatie américaine sera peut-être que
plus habiles et mais moins vulgaire que
les mots de biden mais j'espère beaucoup
cela mais pourquoi il faut comprendre
qu'il ya quand même une wii moscou tout
cas réagi avec une forme quand même un 2
2 2 quand même si j'ose dire on parle d'
insulte attaques contre la russie
rappelle son ambassadeur on l'a dit pour
des consultations médicales même vouloir
éviter la dégradation irréversible des
relations avec les états unis
dans ce cas comment nous quelle peut
être la position de la russie qu'elle
fait l'attitude de la russie face à un
affront même jettent à voir sa pensée
quand on l'a vu d'ailleurs ces dernières
années que le président poutine a quand
même une grande capacité d'encaisser les
coups on le voit très bien bon ils
réagissent que tout à fait normal moi je
trouve ça tout à fait normal que la
russie rappelle son ambassadeur pour des
consultations sas et on ne peut pas
enfin le président russe peut pas
laisser dire des choses pareilles sur
lui-même d'ailleurs ce qui représente
comme un grand pays et puis directement
ce son pays
moi je pense que si vous voulez le dans
cette affaire les
les vins rouges tendance à penser que le
président poutine comme les russes vont
encaisser à tout en agissant de façon de
façon le lucide et puis de façon claire
en dire écoutez mon tout ça ça va mais
n'allez pas trop loin
et puis j'espère que la real politique
derrière tout ça prendra le pas sur des
excitations ou sur l'étape au fonds
américain
mais je suis quand même inquiet de voir
cet état profond américain ce grand
complexe militaro-industriel reprendre
la main ça je le sens avec trump si vous
voulez quand vous allez train tous les
autres n'aimait pas trop
alors il y avait une sorte d'union
d'union de l'europe a dit voilà on va
faire la défense open on doit être
indépendant peut pas très et puis à des
picards et les leaders s'ils voulaient
on a l'impression que la grande volonté
européens de faire une défense
européenne se délite liquéfie et puis on
retombe dans ses vieux travers les
européens qui sont un peu à un peu
dépendants de cette politique américain
m tkm une politique
enfin dans le discours n'est pas une
très belle politique d' équilibre du
monde et notamment du calibre du monde
occidental
justement on s'attendait à un joe biden
assez calme qui jouait un petit peu le
contrepoint fins à un treuil parfois
laver mon provocateur est ce que ce
n'est pas pire ce qui est en train de
faire joe biden parce que pour le coup
c'est très agressif l'habitude
le problème c'est que trump lui était
peut-être agressive dans son
comportement il avait le comportement
tti énervant qu'il était tout le monde
mais en même temps si vous voulez être
un peu mais qu'est ce qu'il a fait c'est
que pendant quatre ans il n'y a pas eu
de tension il ya plus de bière il a
quand même arrêter tous les conflits qu
avec les américains c'est quand même et
sanguinaire est là au contraire on voit
un joe biden nom que l'union européenne
est tout le monde apprécie à dire voilà
la démocratie revient ce qu'ils fussent
progression d'ailleurs ce soit la
démocratie revienne et puis en fait qui
se révèle en fait ce qu'il est le le
porte parole d'un complexe militaro
industriel dans j'espère qu'il arrivera
à retenir ou du moins à ralentir la
pression cela politique américaine une
dernière
c'est vrai que c'est le monde en avait
enfin vous mais je crois le maïs bien se
rend compte que trois cas d'effets
l'union de l'europe et la bidane est en
train de liquéfier la petite volonté de
l'europe d'être indépendante grossesses
qui se passent alors une dernière petite
question sera
les présumés ingérence russe qui
reviennent sur sur la table elles ont
été souvent évoquée notamment par les
démocrates eux
selon moscou ce rapport avec ces
ingérences que je reviens parce que
c'est un prétexte pour remettre à
l'ordre du jour la question de nouvelles
sanctions contre la russie c'est une
forme d'explication écouter entre nous
c'est heureusement quand on a suivi
l'élection américaine présidentielle bon
tout le monde a oublié ce qui s'est
passé mais moi je connaissais je me suis
alors essaie on avait fait un rapport il
ya 4 5 ans on s'est rendu compte que le
système américain n'est pas un système
fiable au niveau des élections on s'est
rendu compte qu'il ya eu des fraudes
tout ça est évacué parce qu'il fallait
élire un président mais attendez ce
président qui a quand même été lu par
une des plus grandes fraudes qu'a connue
les états unis elle avait connu ciel
d'avec avait fait lire kennedy les
amériques avait connue celle qu'avait
fait lire aussi rappelez-vous le fils
bush contre la rapée ou là franchement
il ya eu des excès en fraude qui sont
énormes et qu'est ce qu'on voit on voit
ce président qui a quand même été lue de
façon bon c'était reconnu par la cour
suprême ça va mais afin de façon quand
même un peu surprenante et vous avez ce
président qui reprend un vieux débat qui
date de quatre ans alors soit c'est pour
faire oublier qu'il était lui-même par
une fraude soit c'est peut-être tout ce
souhait des raisons si vous voulez pour
relancer l'attention avec la russie
alors y aider quand vous dites peut-être
pas dans un processus de négociations
sur le nucléaire outre un schéma terre
parce que c'est quand vous commencez à
négocier vous avez intérêt à être dur et
puis quand après là c'est plus facile
pour obtenir des choses que de ça mais
je ne peux pas je n'ai pas suffisamment
d'éléments pour décrypter la réalité de
ceux de cette offensive
be dead cette offensive un peu vulgaire
que mafieuse
on peut le dire les cowboys classique
avec le colt là on en a tiré ses
adversaires je tue l'adversaire c'est
c'est pas du monde actuel ça va pas être
devrait pas exister des mots comme ça
entre ddt président de six grands pays
merci pozzo di borgo d'avoir été avec
mon président de l'institut lecanu et
ancien sénateur udf paris